President Trump will meet with the UN
secretary-general at the White House
today ahead of his summit with North
Korean leader Kim jong-un and multiple
appearances yesterday president Trump
told reporters that plans for the
much-anticipated June meeting are moving
forward
major Garrett is at the White House with
the latest major good morning good
morning it is increasingly clear
president Trump agreed to a summit with
North Korea before his administration
had a unified strategy to pursue
denuclearization there the president's
clash here yesterday with his brand-new
national security adviser highlighted
some of the hard work ahead meanwhile
North Korea's recent hesitancy about
attending the summit provoked a bit of a
new warning from the president nothing
has changed on North Korea that we know
of
president Trump said Thursday that the
administration was still preparing for a
mid-june summit with North Korean
dictator Kim jong-un
despite threats from Pyongyang to back
out we are continuing to negotiate in
terms of location the location it's to
where to meet how to meet rooms
everything else and they've been
negotiating like nothing happened those
words conveyed how much preparation
remains Arizona Republican Senator Jeff
Flake said the administration needs more
time to set the stage I've been
skeptical
someone maybe in six months the summit
was endowed after North Korea objected
to National Security Advisor John
Bolton's assertion the US would follow
the so-called Libya model to achieve
denuclearization in North Korea we're
looking at the Libya model of 2003-2004
Bolton was referring to us supervised
destruction of Libyan nuclear weapons
North Korea worries about what happened
next years later Libyan leader Moammar
Qaddafi was overthrown and killed
well the Libyan model isn't a model that
we have at all well we're thinking of
North Korea mr. Trump said the US would
not seek regime change in North Korea
this would be with Kim jong-un something
where he'd be there he'd be in his
country he'd be running his country the
president also reverted slightly to his
tougher rhetoric that model would take
place if we don't make a deal on a
completely separate topic the president
has tried to clarify a wednesday
reference he made to undocumented
immigrants as animals hearing this the
Mexican government issued a formal
diplomatic protests calling the language
unacceptable this morning on Twitter the
president called original coverage of
this quote wrong saying he was only
referring to members of the violent El
Salvadoran gang ms-13 and he said Nora
he would always refer to them as animals
ok major thank you